historically money has been used as a
way to control other people for example
in ancient times ancient Mesopotamian
times it was illegal to sell your family
your wife or son into slavery unless you
were settling a debt so what does that
show us show us it shows us that money
can make us act very irrationally but
awesome very dangerously right what is
slavery slavery is but a type of debt of
controlling other people and so what's
happened over the years over the
generations over the civilizations the
people who issue the money they like to
control the money because they realize
if they can water down the value of it
or they can increase the value of it
they can change people's behaviors so as
a business person it's important to
realize that money is not the only thing
coming to relationships meaning that you
shouldn't have value all your business
leads or business contacts in terms of
money because money makes us do
irrational things and often selfish
things in the business context so in
part of researching this book I wanted
to look at the idea of religions what do
different spiritual masters say about
money I mean 80% of what Jesus says in
terms of his parables and the book of
Matthew are about money
they're about there are over 80 verses
in the Quran having to do with money or
wealth in some way in Hinduism there's
two there's four aims of life but two of
them really matter to this topic of
money one of them is called artha artha
what does artha mean it means that you
have to go out and make material wealth
it's okay to make wealth it's your duty
to make wealth because you have to take
care of your family you have to make a
living but the pursuit of artha the
pursuit of money will leave you yearning
for more will leave you empty and
that'll mean you'll need to go for the
fourth aim of life which is moksha
liberation from it detachment from it so
it's the pursuit of artha that leads you
to the liberation of it which is very
nuanced a sophisticated way of looking
at money this corresponds to periods of
your life for example when you're young
and early in your life you should be
trying to make money you're due to be
trying to take care of yourself if
you're working on Wall Street if you're
a stockbroker it's okay to make the
money but as you leave this world you
should start to renounce from a
attach it because they certainly don't
take it with you this can also
correspond to periods every day in the
morning you go to work you make a living
make some money but when you come home
you should unplug from it you should
detach from the money-making pursuit and
try to balance your life in that way so
there's a reason to cross all the
faith's across all the fates they talk
about less is more so someone that so
many of us are driven by more is better
but it's important to realize that
sometimes less is more